Thank you.
Hey, Melissa.
I was just thinking about you, and I apologize.
I had a very difficult week.
I'm going to leave it at that because it's a public space.
There's really no excuse, but I will have something for you very soon.
I know that you don't, you know, you've never asked to come up and speak, so I know that's
not your interest.
I'm not sure how long we're going to be waiting here.
I mean, I think Morgan's going to come up and I don't want to put this on like 15 minutes.
Let's see if anyone else shows up.
You showed up and that's more than enough for me, but I do want to wait another 10 minutes
before I start rambling on because then people miss, if anyone shows up, they'll come in halfway
without knowing what I said.
Hey, Sal, wait in about 10 minutes to start talking just so that I won't have to repeat
myself any more than I already do.
Right.
And while we're waiting, I'm working on the, uh, my, see, my real hobby isn't the spaces.
My real hobby is making the, uh, little memes to advertise the spaces.
And it's ridiculous, but I was never in a band.
I was never musical, but when I was growing up in the nineties, uh, everyone had a goddamn
band.
Everyone was in the garage.
They were all playing music.
They weren't very good, but they were a lot better than I was.
And everyone was post everywhere you would go up on the, um, like laundromats and telephone
poles would be these, uh, uh, posters that they hobbled together, cutting, you know, um,
cut and paste before computers even.
And they're very cool.
Hey, Morgan.
They're very cool posters, uh, for, for me at that time.
Right.
Like, I don't know if I think they were cool today as an older adult, but at the time they
were cool.
And I was very, uh, I don't envy many things, but I probably envy the posters.
I think in retrospect, uh, because now I really look forward to making the little UFO X posters,
which no one really appreciates, but me, but I love making them.
Um, and I think I'm going to, uh, try to run a space tomorrow on UFO X and the train wreck
that it's becoming.
Now, no one really asked me to, and it really, no one, I don't think anyone necessarily needs
my criticism, but I feel like, you know, I feel like I just got to get it out of my system
because I don't talk to most of these people directly.
And I'm not, I've never associated myself with UFO X, but was associated by, um, by proximity,
I guess.
Uh, but I just, I just feel like, you know, more people need to talk about what a fucking,
excuse my language, train wreck, um, it's become with everyone celebrating each other's
physical injuries.
And, uh, I don't know, all kinds of crazy stuff.
So I might do that tomorrow, but, uh, today we're going to talk about, um, I don't know,
the stuff that I got on the list, the Astro RV and, uh, oh, uh, catechism.
Yeah, actually, you know what?
This is a good thing to do, um, cause we got our main place here.
So, um, I might as well just start now talking about this.
So the first one is, um, the first thing I wanted to talk about today, uh, because I,
I've touched on this before, but I don't think I've articulated very well.
Now, I may not articulate it very well now either.
That's quite possible.
Um, I'm sorry.
I, I, I wrote a little list, a jot list today, which usually makes things better, but my handwriting
is indecipherable to myself even.
So there's one on the list and I can't figure out what it is.
So I guess maybe it wasn't that important to begin with.
Oh, now I know.
Okay.
So anyhow, um, simulation, right?
Like I've, I've had talked to people and it's been more than one person who has said to
me, uh, they can either understand, um, catastrophicism, like the theory of periodical, periodic catastrophes
and the effect they have on history or simulationism.
But, uh, simulationism and catastrophicism don't make sense to them.
Um, and we've, we've never done, like, I really should do like a full, like three hours as
a moment.
I have a full three hours and bring it all together.
And like, instead of just showing up and rambling on, I should have a full, like written
summary in front of me.
So I can stay focused, um, cause this is actually like very important.
It's like the core of what we're trying to talk about.
Um, so from this perspective, right?
Like there's the, the, the, the people who generally believe in simulationism believe that everyone
here is involved in some kind of video game.
And some people, um, might be players in that video game.
Like they may exist outside the simulation and they may be here in order to have the experience
of being in the simulation.
And other people might be NPCs, non-player characters generated by the computer, but everything
that's going on, generally speaking in simulation theory, the way it's expressed today is happening
inside of a computer.
It really, it shows people aren't thinking things through very clearly because obviously
if you believe people are, uh, in a virtual reality simulation, right?
If you believe people are part of some sort of video game, then it, it's happening inside
of their minds, right?
The events aren't happening inside of the computer.
So if you're going to say like, we're all in a simulation, therefore we're all computer
programs, like that makes sense to people, but it doesn't actually make sense if you think
about it, right?
Like it makes sense to people like who are thinking of things kind of superficially and
they, with confirmation bias, they're looking for certain answers, right?
They, they have a certain set of beliefs and they're, they're trying to explain what's going
on according to those beliefs.
If this is a virtual reality simulation, then the events are happening inside of people's
minds.
And even if you have say NPCs, right?
They're not necessarily a computer program as much as they're like a computer generated dream,
right?
Because the events are all happening inside of, of a, of an actual physical biological system.
Now, when we first started talking about this, um, and people have been writing about this
for thousands of years, but Morgan and his group intuitive underground, right?
They've been, um, working on their Canon project for, I believe more than 10 years now.
Now, during that time, um, very few people were talking about the interface of biology and technology.
And when they did, they were focusing on the technology and not on the biology.
It's only after we first, like the news broke after we first started talking about the, not,
it's not because of us.
It's just a correlation.
Uh, after we first started talking about this on the internet, on X, uh, last year, the
news started to break about people actually going out and creating computer chips and computers
that run on cloned human brain cells.
And it sounds crazy to say it, like if you had talked about this in the nineties or even
20 years ago, you'd, you'd risk being put on a mental health hold, but it's true.
It's true.
And it, it, it came out after we started talking about it and there's an Australian company
hosted the link many times that builds these little boxes.
Now that's kind of scary for other reasons because little boxes containing quote people's
souls come up in abduction, um, phenomena reports.
So I think we've done a different, um, I think we did a different space on that.
We should probably do another one in the future, uh, but it's called like the black box of Saturn.
This is a real thing.
And people have been reporting it and abductions for years that, um, they've been, they've had
their consciousness removed from what they perceive to be their body and put into this box.
Now that's super creepy to think about.
It's even creepier that these Australians have created these boxes.
They're white in this case, where they have human brain cells in them running a computer.
And the first thing they did was teach them to play pong, right?
So the first thought they had was to teach them to play a game, right?
As opposed to like the first thing they did was, was testing their ability to solve mathematical
problems.
The first thing they did when they created the system was create a simulation.
So for those brain cells, the very first thing they ever did, the very first thing they ever
experienced was a simulation involving the game pong.
Uh, after that, um, I don't know if they've done any work on like the, the usual problems that
one would use with a computer, um, maybe they have, and they just haven't, um, publicized
it, but they moved on to simulating the game doom.
And that made the news because not only is, you know, not only is it creepy to have
little, um, I believe they call them organelles, little brains being used to run a computer.
Um, but now instead of having them play pong, the second thing you do is create a simulation
of them being a first person shooter in hell, which is apparently what doom is.
Doom's been around for a long time.
I've never played doom.
I don't think maybe years and years ago, but it's, it's a sort of like cult thing in, in
the computer science profession, um, to encode doom on things like to find new ways to encode
information.
And the first thing they do is encode the game doom.
Uh, I think they did it on a rice kernel of rice at one point in time, they were able
to find a way to encode information on the rice.
And the first thing they did was encode the game doom.
Who knows?
I mean, I think we know, right.
Why psychologically, the first thing that the person would be driven to do when they created
this new way of, of, um, storing, uh, data was encode the game doom on it, right.
A simulation about being a first person shooter in hell.
Um, but I don't think as a society, we know that, right.
Just the people who come to these spaces.
Um, so what we're talking about is, uh, is a lot more complex than that.
And when you, when you approach the fact that the way the, um, the brain would experience
it would either be, um, would either be the way that we do like experience waking life,
which, you know, if you were familiar with a lot of the, um, a lot of the ancient religious
beliefs, a lot of the, um, indigenous cultural beliefs, whatever, you know, they see the, the,
what we consider to be waking life as a form of dream, right.
Um, as do I, but we can, we can, for the sake of this argument, we can say, okay, there's
being awake and there's being asleep and dreaming.
So, um, the problem with having a waking brain solving problems in, uh, when you merge biology
and technology together is that you, you know, it's sort of assumed that the, the, the individuals
involved or the brains involved or whatever it is, right.
Don't have access to sensory data.
They are being presented with, uh, fake sensory data in order to harness their ability to solve
a problem, but they are, they're not directly perceiving the world.
Like an example of what it would look like to be, um, a biological system running, uh, technological,
um, running a technological system in a waking real world environment might come from the show,
Dr. Who, right?
Like Daleks and Cybermen.
Although I think technically, uh, you know, um, I'm a, I like Dr. Who, but I'm not a fanatic.
I think technically speaking, the Cybermen are dead.
So maybe the, uh, anyhow, if you, if you wanted to understand what that would look like, uh,
that would look like a Dalek or a Cybermen, right?
So you'd be in a, in a metal body or an artificial body, but you'd be directly perceiving the world
everyone else perceives, um, in the case of a virtual reality simulation, you're, you're perceiving
artificial data and we might assume the way that it's like likely to work is in a dreamlike state.
So it's like an induced collective dream.
And therefore when we're analyzing it, we can analyze it from the perspective of, of how our daily lives relate to dreams, right?
So if you look at, um, archetypal analysis, Young or Freud, Freud was the first one who started talking about the unconscious.
A lot of people don't, don't know that Freud talks about archetypes other than like sexual stuff.
The sexual stuff is predominant, but, um, everyone here might've taken, um, uh, a Freudian archetype personality test where they'll ask you things like,
what's your favorite tree?
Tell me three, give me three adjectives to describe the tree.
Um, you, you're walking on a beach and you find a key.
What do you do with the key?
If you've ever taken one of those personality quizzes online, that's a Freudian archetypal personality quiz.
And the reason that it works is because the archetypes, um, that we, that we can analyze in dreams, those meanings are universal to us, whether we're dreaming or not.
So a tree has an archetypal meaning to us in our waking life and in our dream life.
We just don't perceive it as directly in our waking life as our dream life.
But if I ask you, uh, Hey, um, you know, Hey, Sally, Melissa, Morgan, what's your favorite tree?
Give me three adjectives to describe that tree.
Right.
Um, what that signifies is the way you look at life, the way you look at life in general, the way you look at your life in particular.
And so looking at that and the way that you answered it, we can, we can get a, a good idea about how you see life.
Right.
And if you were like, hypothetically, I'm sure no one here said this, but if you were like, uh, you know, what's your favorite tree?
And you pick like, um, you know, some kind of like really rough tree and your adjectives were like really rough.
Then we might say like, this person is depressed.
Right.
But if you picked, um, you could be like, uh, I'm trying to think of trees now, like a willow tree.
You know, you could be like, it's, it's, uh, it's, uh, flexible.
It's a beautiful.
It's whatever you might say.
Right.
And like, those would be, would tell us how you look at life.
Generally speaking, it's positive.
You'll find some people who will be like palm tree because it's like people party under it.
And, you know, that, you know, they're in invariably, there's somebody who is, um, you know, very living in the now, uh, often a drinker or a dancer, you know, it just, it gives us, it, um, archetypes communicate, um, information.
In a very, um, condensed, elegant way.
Archetypes are almost like compression in a computer and they might be in compression in a computer, but, um, so the meaning ascribed to events in dreams and dream analysis is also true in, in waking life.
So, um, it's on the level of dream analysis on the level of personality analysis.
And when you look at the ancient world, right?
Um, they had omens and it's, it's based on the same principle, the principle that life is a waking dream.
So the way a bird would fly, um, what type of bird, um, I think everyone here has probably heard, like if a bird comes into your house, that has a certain meaning.
Uh, I don't support, um, and I don't think it's accurate to say that if a bird flies in your house, someone's going to, but that is an old superstition.
It traces back to the time when people would look at the events that occur around them and they would draw inference about events that were going to occur in the future based on these omens.
And the reason that worked, Hey, bark like a duck.
Again, the reason that worked is because things have symbolic meanings in our dreams and in our philosophical world.
And in our waking life, in the world around us, I would speculate that the reason for that is that this is a simulation.
This world is a simulation running on biological hardware.
So the tree outside my window that I'm looking at right now, it exists for me in my waking life.
It exists as a, as a symbol in my mind and it exists as a symbol or archetype in a dream that I'm experiencing.
So it, the information is communicated on all three levels.
All right.
When you look at dream analysis, the other predominant theory, um, aside from the unconscious mind communicating to us in dreams, um, right.
Or there are two other theories, probably, right.
You have the new age theory where, or the meditative or esoteric theory that we're out in the astral plane in our dreams, um, having actual experiences.
There are some, there's actually some reason to believe that in a sense is accurate.
Um, if you look at reality as, as being a dream, then the dream world is another layer of that dream reality, right?
It's a dream inside a dream.
And, and so from that perspective, the astral plane could, could very well be real.
Um, what they call the astral plane originally, we call space.
Now, a lot of people don't recognize that, but that's what it is.
And I'm not saying like space doesn't exist in our material analysis.
Um, I'm just saying that historically, right.
That's what the astral plane was.
Now we talk about it like it's something vague that we don't quite understand, but that's, that's what, how the esotericists saw it.
Like, like, so the astral plane was space that the earth was, um, part of as sort of a discrete element.
That was a different plane, the earth plane or the material plane, or however you want to describe it.
Um, there's also a theory that, uh, and this is something I struggled with, um, when I was originally a student in the esoteric, there are some esoteric gurus or whatever, who, who wrote at length about the fact that, uh, when you have dreams, the events that occur in your dreams are things that are occurring in the world around you while you sleep.
Uh, so you hear a bird chirping outside your window and you dream of a bird, you hear the sink, uh, dripping in your bathroom.
So you dream of running water.
And I always thought that's so lame, right?
Because clearly archetypal analysis and symbolism and dreams is, um, is compressed information.
Like you, you get a tremendous amount of information from analyzing a person's dreams and thinking critically about them, um, information about the past, present and future sometimes.
Um, and what I didn't recognize at that time was that those esoteric gurus knew, right?
They were part of traditions that, that did teach the fact that our waking life is a form of collective sleep.
And so what those esoteric teachings actually mean is that there is a world around us the same way when your faucet drips, you can dream of running water.
When there's a bird outside your window, you can dream of a bird or, um, and this has happened to me a couple of times in my life.
When there's someone scream, when you're in a deep sleep and two people break into a screaming argument, there is both a screaming argument in your real life, but there also may be a screaming argument in your dream.
Right.
Or when the TV is on and it's something crazy on the TV and so you have a dream about similar things.
Okay.
That happens.
But what the esoteric teaching actually means is that there is a portion of our, of our dream world, which is giving a window, uh, providing a window for us into the real world beyond our waking world.
The deeper reality, the one that we can't directly perceive with our senses, right?
Exists, it's real, it's material in some sense, more material than, than, than what we experienced as waking reality.
And the events that occur there trickle into our consciousness and our conscious awareness here.
I was not the person who invented this.
I'm the only person who talks about it.
I was not, I can't tell you where I first read it or heard it.
Uh, it's just lost in my memory.
Cause it was something that I ran into, like hearing someone speak.
Like I didn't take notes.
I don't have a source, but it's stuck with me since then.
And I've had this personal experience after my automobile accident, uh, about on the third day after a serious life threatening accident.
Um, it's normal to have dreams, nightmares about the accident.
Um, and I had like, my heart was up to 185 beats a minute, I think all night long tossing and turning.
Well, no, actually feeling like I was tossing and turning.
I actually couldn't move.
Um, but like filled with nightmares and I had nightmares of, well, I had nightmares the whole night that I was in hell, but let's set that aside.
Cause that's a philosophical argument for a different space.
Um, I had nightmares of a female Fox headed figure taking pieces of me, taking pieces out of me.
And although I was like, I was cognitively in real trouble for six months to two years after my accident.
I still maintain, I mean, I, this isn't like, I'm not trying to humble brag, humble brag.
What I'm saying is like, if you take someone who knows like a bunch of stuff and you put them into a situation where they're kind of cognitively impaired, they still know a bunch of stuff, right?
Like they might not know as much as they did before.
So I was, um, I, I, I was like, seriously, um, I couldn't think straight at all or solve problems, but I did recognize what was going on, um, the day after.
Um, and that is that the, the Fox headed female character taking pieces out of me and my dream, um, in hell was a nurse in the OR and that, um, the anesthesia doesn't always work a hundred percent.
And you can have PTSD, um, you can have PTSD where you remember events that occurred during the surgery.
And that's, that's what happened to me.
I know I'm making this long winded.
I'm gonna try to wrap it up, Sally, uh, cause I know you asked about it.
Okay.
So, uh, previously to me.
Um, so I think that that's what happens.
Someone else mentioned this.
I think that's what happens to some people who are having UFO abduction experiences.
I think that what they're remembering is something related to an anesthesia, like event that's occurring in base reality, earth prime, whatever you want to call it.
The reality beyond our waking reality, like something is happening.
Something real is happening.
That real thing is involving real people.
When they talk about screen memory, right?
We talk about like a screen memory that a person who has a UFO abduction can experience in waking life where they'll have, um, they'll see an owl and they'll lose time and then they'll be under hypnotic regression.
And it's not an owl, it's a gray.
And then they're under more, more hypnotic regression.
It's, it's not a gray, it's a person.
It's, it's a military person.
It's like a, an episode for, um, of the X-Files that you can have these layers of false,
false memories that conceal a real memory underneath it.
I believe that for some people, what is occurring when they have, um, uh, memories of UFO abduction experience is, is a recollection of something where the, the, the aliens in the abduction experience are a screen memory for the individuals that they are interacting with on a, on a real level.
So events outside, um, of whatever type of simulation a person might experience.
Like if you're in that little box, now they don't have senses.
So I don't know how much they sense, but let's just say they have access to some sort of sensory data, but it's highly limited.
So that little brain organelle has to try to make sense of whatever data you can get from outside that box.
And that information might be channeled through its, its dreaming and come out as whatever type of dreams it would, it would have.
Right.
So it would be like screen images in a dream.
And sometimes archetypes are like that.
So when you get into the role of like, what are catastrophes in a simulation?
Um, I think we've used the example of thunderstorms, right?
Um, we use the metaphor of a brainstorm.
If you're, um, if you're thinking about something and you're coming up with a lot of ideas and all of a sudden, and I think we've all had that experience, right?
Where like, you feel like there's a storm in your brain.
Like you feel differently and you, you can't feel your brain directly, but you feel like, um, you can feel like a tingling or excitement or an energy or electricity as you, as you're firing off these creative ideas.
And we say, oh, that's a brainstorm.
And we act as if we're using storms as a metaphor for what's going on in our brain.
But the deeper truth may be, um, that, uh, and this is, if you asked indigenous elders, perhaps, right?
Like cultures that have rain dances.
So what's happening is when you do a rain dance, right?
On a surface level, you might have a culture that thinks it's appeasing some sort of God, but on another level, you'd have cultures that have more information.
Understanding that there is a connection between the rain and the human soul or human mind.
And, um, uh, rain dance is an attempt to hack that previously existing connections.
All right.
So, um, to use the, the, the signal to, to control the event a little bit, it's quite possible that what we look at is like the Schumann resonance and lightning and storms, whatever our, our internal perception of events occurring on a biological level to us outside the simulation.
So the, there's the, there's an event that's actually occurring in the brain.
And then as dreamers, we're experiencing that as lightning and storms.
And using that, like, hopefully that's, cause I, I know I say that sometimes and I don't know if I'm, if it's clear enough or, but if you, if you hear what I'm saying,
um, the catastrophes that occur, all right, inside a simulation, they, they, they serve two purposes or they, it's on two levels.
Uh, so what is the purpose of the simulation?
I don't think we, we articulate this enough.
And this is gained from all kinds of sources.
This is not drawn directly entirely from I use information.
So when I talk about this, I'm not directly quoting them and it shouldn't be understood to be like, uh, to represent how they feel necessarily.
And what their data is necessarily as, as, as so much as their one source, right?
So I, cause I don't want to, to make it seem like they take ownership of what I'm saying.
Um, the purpose of the simulation is to create emergent data.
Um, there's clearly a lot of information that comes through involving the individuals themselves, the human beings, the beings, whatever they are, whatever we are, et cetera, being used as batteries to power the simulation.
And that tends to be what people focus on when they look at remote viewing data or films or esoteric information about the simulation is the, the fact that, um, it's being powered by the people in some way.
That's one level, but we also know that, uh, DNA can be used to store information.
It's a far more efficient way of storing information than any other type of hard drive, right?
So like in the future, hard drives, hard drives, um, instead of like storing things on hard drives or those little, uh, sticks, I always forget the term for, or floppy disks or whatever, right?
They're going to be storing information on DNA.
That's unless they find something more efficient.
I doubt they will more efficient and cheaper, right?
So you're going to have like a little bit of DNA.
God only knows where it'll be from and all of your information will be stored on that.
And so it only makes sense that, um, in a biological simulation, the same thing would occur.
Um, and the purpose of the simulation itself is to create emergent solutions.
We do have data on that, not necessarily from IU, although there might be some, but we have it from other remote viewers.
And we just have it from understanding, creating simulations and ourselves, ourselves in this waking reality, we create simulations.
And the purpose of those simulations is to generate emergent data.
It's to, um, generate unexpected, um, conclusions and connections that people generally don't make, um, intentionally, right?
Like that, but to come up with ideas that, that the rest of us missed.
That's sort of what we're using AI for, right?
AI doesn't really think it recombines things, but it recombines things in ways that we may never have thought to recombine them.
That's the goal.
So, um, creating unusual solutions to problems.
So how does this all tie together with the simulation theory?
Um, I, I'm going to, I'm going to try this in five minutes and move on to other stuff.
Cause I know how long winded I am.
Um, like why is life full of suffering?
Well, life is full of suffering because the goal of the simulation is to come up with solutions to problems.
So there's no sense in having any event that doesn't have some sort of problem connected to it.
One thing you realize about life, if you study it closely enough, is that every problem that you can conceive of is somebody else's or something else's solution to another problem.
And that's why there's resistance to change, by the way, like people don't want to change.
Life doesn't want to change and will actively resist any type of change because whatever you're trying to change is the solution to God only knows how many problems before it.
And so you threaten someone, if you try to change them, you threaten, um, you threaten their, their, their, their ability to like maintain homeostasis by solving problems.
Um, when you threaten all those solutions that they have, right?
Like whatever it is.
Um, maybe you don't want to, I'm just, I'm just trying to come up with something, right?
Like maybe you don't want someone to own a gun, but they own that gun because they feel insecure and, you know, and they don't feel safe and they own the gun because they go hunting.
And that's how they eat.
And they own the gun because they're, um, their father or mother always owned guns.
And it's something that they had like a strong connection emotionally between them.
So like when you threaten to take away that gun, you're, you're also threatening their security.
You're threatening their ability to feed themselves.
You're threatening their emotional connection to their parents and their heritage, right?
Every problem.
And I'm not saying I see guns as a problem.
That's not my thing, but I just, this is the first thing that popped into my mind.
Like every problem is a, is a solution or a number of solutions.
That's what reality conserves.
That's what natural selection is.
Right.
Um, that's what the, you know, when you look at the Buddhist life is suffering.
Life is suffering, um, natural selection, right.
Is the process of creating emerging solutions to problems in nature and then conserving those.
But every time like a little bird develops a longer beak that gives it an advantage over
the other birds, the other birds are in trouble, right?
That advantage is good for that one bird, but then there's a lot of other birds who are now
going to starve and their descendants are going to starve unless they change.
Right.
And that one little bird, by the way, that does a bit better.
It's surviving long enough to increase its odds of being preyed on or look at human beings,
right?
We survive long enough now to, to have a really rough end of our lives.
I'm not, you know, we all, I'm not trying to tell people like, don't, don't empathize
with your parents.
I do.
What I'm saying is like, we all also know, right.
How often at a certain point in our life do we look at people who are much older than
ourselves and say, Oh, I don't want to live that long.
Well, the reason we say that is because they have so many problems.
The longer you live in this world, the more problems you're going to have, because the
world is optimized to create, give you more and more and more problems and suffering in
order to, to maximize the chance of, of you creating as many solutions as possible during
your life, emergent solutions.
And at, at the level that we're at, that may only be one emergent solution per a million
lives.
A person might have a hundred thousand problems in their life.
And never come up with an emergent solution.
Maybe only one out of a million does, but that's the purpose of the simulation, right?
So when you say like a computer can solve problems that have like all these numbers of zeros,
trillions of zeros, that's trillions of, break that down into trillions of context units
that are all a problem, right?
So computers that solve giant problems are solving a collection, a near infinite level
of little problems that are all stacked together.
And that's why so many people can go through life and it just sucks for them, right?
And you say, well, what's the purpose?
What's the meaning in that?
Well, the meaning is that one out of a hundred thousand, one out of a thousand, one out of
a hundred, whatever it is, um, one out of a million creates something new.
So that both changes the lives of everyone who's involved in this simulation, but also
with something that can be harvested by the individuals running the simulation, right?
They're taking that data and applying it to base reality.
That's what's going on.
So if somebody invents, um, invents a new way to tie shoelaces, or, uh, that's really
ridiculous example.
Um, a new type of chemical, that's a better example.
Someone invents a new type of chemical or metal, um, there might be someone harvesting
that information and, and using it to build a new type of chemical or metal on, on base
reality.
So that, that's what the purpose is, right?
So what's the purpose of the catastrophes?
Well, um, it's twofold.
One, it's when you're getting close to the end of, uh, of a simulation that you have to
keep dialing up the problems because you have so many solutions.
Right.
You get to the point where people live to be 90 years old and, you know, they're living
in, you know, big heated houses and they're getting fat cause they have so much food and
like, you gotta just keep dialing up the problems bigger and bigger and bigger until you finally
start milking it for the juice, you know, um, the, the solutions.
Um, and finally, that comes to the point where, you know, the only way to really, um, increase
or maintain the value you're gaining from the simulation is to create really big problems.
And those really, really big problems are the periodic catastrophes.
The other thing that's happening is, um, the stages in the catastrophes are, are maybe,
right?
The experience of the individuals that we're having, right?
Like the experience of the individuals inside the simulation slash reality overlay of what's
occurring outside.
So, uh, we had a remote viewer, um, doesn't work with us, but, uh, generated some, some data
on this subject.
And what they saw was, um, during a magnetic pole reversal that, that basically the end of
this was a magnetic pole reversal.
And during that magnetic pole reversal, there was a degaussing effect that, um, that a lot
of people, most people involved, like most people in the world around us, the apparent
world, whatever we want to call it, earth, most people on earth, uh, lost their memories,
a hundred percent wiped amnesia so that after the magnetic pole reversal, you had, um, 15%
of the population running around like rabid zombies and 99% of everyone who's left with
no memory at all.
And one out of 10,000 people making it through, uh, with their full memory.
Okay.
So going on that data, I looked into it and it turns out that other people have that, um,
same, um, the same, those same perceptions and what the perception is of somebody actually
taking the data, putting it onto like a disc or a book or, uh, a device and putting that
on a shelf and other intuitive psychics have, um, have received that same information that
the consciousness of each simulation, each epoch, each epoch historically is, is stored away,
right?
The sum of the data generated, the sum of the solutions to the problems is physically stored
someplace during the end of a, of a simulation period during the end of a historical cycle.
And so that's what a magnetic pole shift, what we experienced as a magnetic pole shift and
or physical pole shift, because people argue that you also have physical events occurring,
right?
That super catastrophe at the end of the age that happens every 12,000 years is a catastrophe
that we're experiencing is like, you know, fire and brimstone or ice, like freezing is, um,
them shelving the information, right?
Is the process.
So we're having a dream.
The information is being extracted from the dreaming mind and put onto a piece of media and
stored away.
And the dreaming mind is experiencing that inside the dream as the dream of a massive crisis.
It's actually really sad and Gothic to think about, but it's just like, think about someone
in a coma, right?
You've got someone in a coma, they're having, but it's a dreaming coma.
They're having all this dreaming and somebody extracts all the information from those dreams.
And that mind in the coma is responding to that event by having this dream of this massive,
horrible crisis, this massive, massive catastrophe, because that's what it is.
Everything is being stripped from it, right?
So the memory is being stripped from it, the right, the buildings are collapsing, the sky is
on fire, the oceans are boiling, and it's the psychic processing.
Of the trauma of the shutdown, of the wiping of one simulation in the start of another simulation.
Basically, so that's how they intersect, right?
So it's the, the catastrophe is a dream of the events that are occurring at the end of
the simulation, outside the simulation, basically.
And at the end of that, you wind up with, from what we've been able to ascertain, right?
You wind up with the information shelf, you wind up with a bunch of people with amnesia,
white, right?
Like you wind up with these residuals.
Now, what's interesting about this is once we look into it, you find this everywhere.
Like as soon as you, as soon as you make a leap with this information, using the data and
perceptions gained from modern remote viewers, you can go back and reframe esoteric information
going back for thousands of years.
And so this is what we find.
Now, I don't want to, I don't want to piss in anyone's pond, but no one cares what I say
because I'm, I'm fairly anonymous as a person.
So I'll tell you that, um, after exposure to that information, I went back and restudied
the Kabbalah.
I've never been into the Kabbalah.
Um, I'm just not into like virtue signaling and like, no offense to anyone.
I'm not into like joining esoteric communities as a virtue signal.
Right.
And I think that's, uh, what, when the language is still esoteric and it's all about discovering
the actual meaning of the words and terms and whatever through levels and grades.
And that's just not for me.
It's just, it's not my thing.
Um, but going back, like, this is what, you know, what's, you find it both in like esoteric
history and you find it in, um, Gnostic, uh, studies like Kabbalah that have come down through
the course of time, wherein you find there are phenomenon that are conserved between one
simulation and the next simulation.
Right.
So that exists as a series of problems in the Kabbalah and in other esoteric studies where
you have these residual, uh, beings, residual forces, uh, mostly negative that have made
it through one simulation to the other without being recycled.
Um, in esoteric science, uh, esoteric Christianity, you can go back to Rudolf Steiner, right?
A hundred years ago where, um, the characters, the, the, the characters in his, I don't want to say
mythos, but his clear, his encapsulation of his clairvoyant data contains, uh, a number
of characters, um, of prominence in this cycle, right?
One of them is Lucifer, uh, another is Ahriman.
And the origin of those characters is that they survived from the last simulation into this
simulation, um, to go on and become these, um, these characters in the, the narrative.
So, um, it's this whole thing, but that's, that's where the catastrophes inside of simulations
occur.
They occur as part of the, the nature of the simulation to generate solutions to problems.
And they occur and they occur as a psychic reaction or emotional processing of the, the changes
in the simulation.
And if you were to go down this road and accept this as reality, you could look around at things
that are happening sort of in the world, um, today from, uh, the metaphor of computer science,
right?
So you could say that, um, you know, the fact that you don't see people out after nine
o'clock in a lot of places, uh, or the, the, the time when the streets empty out is getting
earlier and earlier, even in urban environments.
And you see people engaging in less social interaction on all levels of our society, right?
You could see that as, um, a response to a CPU problem, right?
Where, uh, the total number of interactions was too taxing on the system.
So as you get to the close of the simulation, you begin to reduce certain, um, types of social
interaction or certain types of interaction and problem solving, right?
And the way that, that people inside of it, like if you had a computer program running on
your computer and you were like trying to save right space and save processing power, you'd
start reducing parts of that simulation in your computer.
And for someone inside that simulation, things would just sort of weirdly start to disappear.
We're just like, wow, you know, um, when I was younger, uh, I'll give you a great example.
I'm not saying this is, I'm not, you know, I'm not saying this is reason I'm just going
through a thought experiment, right?
Like I wanted to fill my, I wanted to vacuum my car.
It was nine o'clock at night.
I live on in, in the greater Boston area, which is a major American city.
And, um, when I was growing up, uh, there were probably 10 places you would go to vacuum
your car at nine o'clock at night.
Cause there were people up, like there were crowds of young people and even middle-aged
people in restaurants and coffee shops.
And you'd go to like, uh, uh, a minor highway and there'd be like a place open where you could
get your car washed 24 hours.
There's like, that doesn't exist around here anymore.
And I drove around again.
I think I've done this before, like 40 minutes or an hour trying to find a place where I could
vacuum my car at nine o'clock at night.
And there was no one nowhere.
Right.
You know, people say, well, society and culture has changed.
It has, but is that something that lacks any symbolic meaning?
No, everything has symbolic meaning because we're existing in more than one, at more than
one level.
Right.
So the collective unconscious is just as real.
And the Unus Mundi, when we talk about, um, base reality, right?
Like it may sound weird.
It may even sound crazy.
People don't recognize the fact that that is right.
That idea, not only does it go back for thousands of years, but it's deeply built into Jungian
psychology.
Now, Jungian psychology can be stigmatized by other branches of psychology, right?
But Carl Jung, who is often quoted and whose teachings like make up a big part of our, of
our modern psychology, like called it the Unus Mundi, the one world.
Like he, he, you know, it is part of Jungian psychology.
There is a real, a Unus Mundi, there is a one world that we can't perceive.
One way that people liken it is, uh, if you ever, um, had that experiment when you were
young where you had a piece of paper and you put iron filings on the piece of paper, you
took a magnet and you went under the iron filings, like under the piece of paper, and you move
the magnet to trace designs in the iron filings.
It's the way an extra sketch works, right?
Or did work prior to the digital age.
Um, that's the way that people often describe the Unus Mundi, right?
Like that, the, the magnet, you can't see whatever's going on.
You can't perceive it at all.
All you can perceive is the movement in the iron filings.
Um, and so even something as large as a major catastrophe, a nuclear war, um, pole shift,
a magnetic pole shift, an asteroid impact, an alien invasion, right?
Uh, those would all still be movements in the iron filings.
They would still symbolically represent information from the world that we couldn't perceive.
We couldn't perceive it until we had remote viewing.
And through remote viewing, um, some viewers are able to perceive that.
And those perceptions, at least what they bring back and talk about seems an awfully lot, a lot like people are working in, um, uh, scientists and researchers working in a lab.
All right.
Um, so I hope that helps.
If it doesn't help, I can try to clarify further, but, um, that's basically how it works.
It's also one of the proofs of a simulation, um, two of the proofs of the simulation is, uh, how novel and weird the world gets, right?
Because if you're in a simulation and the simulation is maximized to create novelty and emergent solutions, the world is just going to get crazier and crazier.
Right.
So if you feel that the world is getting crazier and crazier or has in your lifetime, that is a experiential and experimental proof that you're in a simulation.
And, uh, what was the other one?
Oh, the stacking catastrophes.
Okay.
So if you've got this the same way, if you were a scientist in a lab or computer scientist or someone playing a video game, like towards the end, right?
Like the, the psychologically, as we get closer to the end, we feel freer to do wilder things.
So, um, one way that can work is like, if we're going to shut this simulation down.
And we're going to create, maximize problems, then let's get weird with it.
Let's have a cometary impact, a pole shift, an alien invasion, a nuclear war.
Uh, you know, let's, let's take those nuclear.
I don't know.
I've spent my whole life being able to pronounce nuclear, but God only knows why I call it nuclear now.
Um, maybe it was my accident, right?
Let's, let's sandwich those all together.
Let's go out with a big bang, like a fireworks, you know, at the end of a fireworks display,
when they let them all rip at the same time and it all goes crazy.
That's exactly what you'd look for.
If you were looking at like a bunch of people creating an ending or for a stage, like at the
end of a simulation, the end of a game, um, a big party at the, you know, um, when a business
is going out of business, right?
So the stacking catastrophes, uh, the fact that people are talking about a pole shift
now, a magnetic pole shift, cometary impact, a nuclear war, bio-digital convergence, like
all of those things added together and the, the evidence for each one of them, the, the
more that you can add together, the more it looks like, um, that's evidence for the simulation.
So that was an hour, uh, of a 10 minute, um, a 10 minute answer.
Uh, and none of it touching on the world astrology report.
Um, so I'm gonna try to like rapid fire this now.
Um, Morgan is here, everyone.
And, uh, we have six people today.
I don't know.
I don't think we have any anonymous viewers, but that's okay.
Um, we don't need anonymous viewers.
So they're always welcome.
I always, uh, I used to get quite a few anonymous viewers, but, um, hello, you know, uh, you can't
be everything for everyone.
Um, it was good to have Morgan back, uh, at least as a listener.
Um, we, uh, you know, we, we worked on the, um,
Astro RV together, come up with some ideas for it.
Uh, recently there was a second Astro RV, uh, project launched by, uh, World Astrology
Report, um, astrologer Dan Waits, um, someone who I'm fairly critical of, uh, they were working
with Josh Maitland of, um, Rockstar Intuition and Second Sight or Second House Remote Viewing.
Um, someone that I have, I've talked to and I don't have any problem with, I'm not necessarily
critical of him, um, so much as I think he's inexperienced.
And the problem that we have right now, at least in remote viewing is that we have, well,
astrology too, let's be honest.
So the problem we have in astrology, remote viewing, ufology, ufology, right?
We had a lot of late adapters who, um, who don't particularly care for the people who, who
come before them.
Like it's, you know, not to become a generational warrior, but it's a millennial thing.
Um, it's like part of the generational zeitgeist for millennials to, to, uh, feel a complete
disconnection to everything that, that comes before them so that, um, like someone in the
millennial generation can go out and not everyone, but it's just something that happens, go out
and develop a hobby or an interest in say remote viewing and spend a year or two, like really
information mining and, and really studying it.
And when they talk to other people about it or make videos about it, they'll represent
it as their, I, I developed this, I discovered this, it's my thing because, um, they do see
themselves almost like archeologists from a future, like the millennial generation is almost
like a group of archeologists from the future, like dropped into, um, a strange world because
they were raised to have like a complete sense of disconnection from adults, basically.
Um, and a suspicion, um, of, of, uh, adults when they were younger, that they really perceived
themselves as is on a mission of discovery of a lost world when they encounter anything,
um, anything written about or spoken about or conserved by earlier generations.
And so they're able to say like the same way, if you dug in your backyard, you discovered
a, um, a lost temple and it'd be like, I discovered this temple.
This is my temple.
That's the same sense that they have whenever they find information that's new to them.
The problem is, um, in this case, largely the people who've conserved that information and
studied it and become experts in it are still alive.
They're still alive.
We just don't exist in the reality of the millennial generation in that sense.
And I don't know, maybe it's true with generation Z as well.
Right.
But in that sense, there's definitely a barrier that occurred with the millennial generation,
um, that almost makes the millennial generation, a simulation inside a simulation.
They're like basically the bottom simulation in Rick Sanchez's battery.
If you've ever, um, if you've ever paid attention to, uh, Rick and Morty, um, and they, they,
they actually, it's interesting.
I'm going to study that.
I'm going to, I'm going to, I'm going to study that, uh, going forward.
Like their experience is almost like being the world itself, being a simulation, a simulation
inside a simulation.
Yeah.
I'm not being very articulate.
Anyhow.
Um, so what you do is run into people who've got five years of experience, not every millennial,
by the way.
Okay.
Uh, you run into people who've got like five years of experience in a subject and they've
read as about as much as they can find, but they have, they don't have enough experience
to really master the subject.
And, um, and they often, uh, focus on their criticisms of other people's, right.
Um, they have problems with other people's, um, formulations, other people's, um, perspectives,
other people's, uh, knowledge.
And again, the whole, you know, um, every problem is someone else's solution.
They don't recognize that fact.
Right.
And so they, they immediately go into attack mode and differentiate themselves and say,
well, um, other remote viewers aren't good.
Uh, hostile marketing, other astrologers aren't good.
Other ufologists aren't good.
Listen to me, but don't listen to them.
Right.
I've discovered the solution that actually makes this make sense.
They don't, what they do doesn't actually make any sense.
Like they're not really good remote viewers.
They're not good astrologers.
They're not good ufologists.
Um, but I figured it out.
Right.
That's what the person will say to themselves.
And they'll say to others, um, or, you know, um, or they'll say like expertise really doesn't
matter.
Experience really doesn't matter.
You know, we each, um, should be rewarded for doing our own thing, coming up with our own
formulation, very millennial, um, our own method of remote viewing, right.
Our own method of astrology, our own method of ufology.
And you have, everyone else in the world has to treat it as being equal to 2000 years of
human tradition.
Right.
And you have to accept us as being authorities equal to a greater than anyone who's older than
us has more experience than us and is still alive.
Right.
The, those people clearly aren't authorities because they don't have as many followers on
social media.
Now, um, you can have like, uh, you know, we're all getting older, right?
So you've got 40 guys in their forties now who have this, um, who have this mentality, men
and women, you have people in their forties who have this mentality.
It's not just kids, right?
Like this is a, it's an imprint.
It's a, it's a, it's a generational imprint.
Um, and this is what we've run into with, um,
other individuals who want to look into Astro RV, who come up with the idea, um, supposedly
on their own.
I don't believe it.
Uh, I do believe that they believe that they came up with the idea on their own, but again,
we're talking about an entire generation of people who can see something, read it, and
then believe it's their own idea.
Like that's not unusual.
It's very common, unfortunately, or fortunately, I don't know.
Um, so I've, I'm very critical of, uh, of Dan Waite's world astrology report.
I'm not as critical of Josh Maitland, but I'm not a remote viewer and I like him.
He's a good guy.
Um, in my experience, I guess maybe not, who knows, who knows it might on a, on a surface
level, I like him, right?
Um, but as an astrologer, like I, I see the same thing.
Like I would be pissed if I was a remote viewer and I, and I saw what these other guys are
doing.
Guys like Josh, to be honest, trying to lead, um, before they have the experience to do so.
Right.
Um, and using social positioning as a way of trying to climb a ladder, um, rather than doing,
excuse me, just, I just bit my tongue rather than doing the work, um, and, and waiting for
one's turn because that's how it is in astrology.
And, um, Dan is along the same, like he has a hundred thousand followers now, right?
His last video got 400,000 views.
So, uh, I, I'll never, my life be as popular influencer.
I'll never be an influencer, but like, I couldn't, like, I don't have the capability, right?
It can't say that I'm his equal in that sense because I'm not like, I don't have the ability
to be that type of influencer.
So as far as that is concerned, being an influencer, like this guy, you know, his ability is, is,
is far greater than my own.
That hasn't been said.
When it comes to being an astrologer, I'm like fucking Nostradamus compared to that guy.
All right.
Because what these, these astrology influences do, first of all, they don't really believe
in astrology.
They don't.
Um, they are entertained by it.
They like it.
They think it's uncanny.
But when you find somebody who acts surprised when they find evidence for something they're
supposed to believe in, like they, they clearly don't believe in it entirely.
They don't believe in the fate aspect of astrology, that, that the study of astrology is, um, is
an analog simulation model that reveals to us a structure, right?
I, I, the structure of the universe, we can't directly perceive.
They don't, they don't see that.
They, they don't, um, buy into it.
Um, and they crossed the streams because they got together and, uh, Dan and Josh got together
and they've been running astro RV, um, projects and they've been making a mess of it.
Uh, not necessarily because of the RV ability of the individual, individuals involved, but
maybe, right?
Because they're students.
They have a student level of RV.
If you can hear me, hold on.
I just dropped my phone.
If not, I'll be back in a second.
Oh, shit.
God damn this fucking phone, man.
All right.
Um, sure everyone was listening to me.
Fumble with my phone.
Uh, it looks like this thing is still on.
So I had to like enter the security code and everything.
Just make a complete asshole of myself.
Hey, Ryan, you showed up at just the right time.
So, uh, yeah.
Uh, just dropped my phone, fumbled with it.
Uh, made an asshole of myself.
Yeah, Dan Waits, uh, World Astrology Reports, Astro RV Sessions.
It's complete junk.
And it's junk because the, um, the remote viewers are at a student level, which is fine.
Like no one should judge them for that, but they also shouldn't be the first people or among
the first people working on a completely new, um, uh, remote viewing protocol, right?
Um, and Dan himself, uh, he has a very, very comprehensive knowledge of astrology and of, um, history.
He doesn't completely buy into it.
And he doesn't have the experience to understand, um, like how to target something for Astro RV.
So he keeps picking these targets based on his assumptions, which aren't valid with Astro RV, right?
He keeps, um, making these, it's like, look, it's, it's just, it's too much to go into because it's, it's going to seem ridiculous, right?
But there's a difference is there's a mundane astrology, which is the study of the, the, um, his correlations
between historical events and the aspects of the planets in the sky without using a natal chart.
And then his natal astrology, which is when we look at each person, um, we look at their, their natal chart, uh, the sky, when they were born and, um, compare it to events in the sky right now.
And we're able to draw information about, um, what is likely to happen to that individual.
And those natal charts are good for companies, they're good for relationships, they're good
for, um, historical leaders, they're good for like whatever, uh, countries, you know, whatever
you're looking at, right?
So we will look at, when we did our Astro RV project, we were looking at the, um, the chart
for the nuclear age, which is the chart that one would use to predict nuclear accidents and
incidents, right, uh, the choice of mundane astrology, uh, for an Astro RV project is a, is a poor
choice, particularly when the individual involved doesn't have a firm grasp of, of the difference
between mundane astrology and natal astrology and, and, and why mundane astrology has sort of
become a thing, um, as opposed to natal astrology because it's, it's, uh, appeals to people's
universalist sentiments, right?
So, um, it's just the wrong fit, but they keep, he got 400,000 views, right?
For his, his video, the Astro RV project predicting what would occur on April 19th, right?
And they were talking about a building exploding and they were talking about a, you know, uh,
uh, a ship, something happening with a ship and a capsule and a, and a UFO or some sort
of event in space.
Those were all things that Dan himself has a preoccupation with.
So if I had to guess, I would say that the viewers were viewing Dan's preoccupations, his
imagination of what might happen on April 19th, rather than looking at the actual events
on April 19th himself.
That, that would be my assumption.
I'm not an expert.
Morgan is an expert.
I'm not an expert in, um, in, uh, remote viewing project management, but that would be
like, that's the first thing that pops out to me, right?
That they saw exactly what Dan might expect them to see.
The date itself was a poor choice.
Um, again, like I said, it was based on, um, an incomplete, um, grasp of astrology and
inexperience.
Uh, what I pointed out, um, in a previous space, if I was going to look at a date, I would look
at, um, the 11th of April, but you know, what, what I was talking about was a transition, a
pivot point.
So there's this, this thing that people get involved in prediction, want to predict like
big events.
They want to predict explosions when things blow up, right?
When people get shot, uh, it's good for their reputation.
It's good for their, their marketing, right?
Their, their product.
And it also fits a mentality we've all developed that, uh, equates history with, uh, big notable
media events.
Cause we all came up in a media, um, cocoon, right?
And there's no difference for most of us between, um, reality as reported in the media and an actual
reality, right?
So it's another form of simulation basically.
Um, but that's not how history works.
That's not how, you know, mundane astrology is, um, basically the study of, uh, punctuation
marks in a historical narrative.
And, um, when you use astrology to break events, you're using it to predict the quality of a time
you're using it to predict a period when a certain type of event is likely to take place.
You don't want to do like, try to predict when a certain type of explosive event or a certain
type of media event is going to take place.
It's possible to do it, but it's not efficient, right?
It's, it's, well, it's inefficient one because, um, it disincentivized people from preparing
for the event and taking action themselves.
So from someone consulting an astrologer, like you want to provide people with useful intelligence
intelligence and generally speaking, that's not useful intelligence.
Whereas telling people like, you know, this is how you should prepare for this period of
time and you should be watchful during this period of time.
That is, is much, is much more useful intelligence as opposed to putting people into the role of
being a spectator.
You want to put them into the role of being a participant.
All right.
Um, and astrology is about, um, is about giving people tools to be a participant, um, rather
than entertaining them as a spectator, which is what an astrological influencer does is, is
presents people with entertainment as spectators, puts people into a spectator consciousness.
Um, and I stand by, uh, April 11th, I complete, I stand by April 11th, April 12th as being a
pivotal turning point.
And if you look back, uh, prior to that, do you see that we had people reporting on the,
um, events of the energy shock and what would occur.
And then right around that period, that's when people started blowing up pipelines and blowing
up refineries.
I mean, officially they're not blowing them up, uh, but there have been like 10 or 11 refineries
and pipelines that have experienced mysterious explosions since that period of time.
Right.
Um, and the actual preparation for the energy shock, um, was all hypothetical up until that
weekend.
And now it's very real, um, as well as natural disasters, right?
Like the earthquake in Japan have, have been on a strong uptick.
So I, I stand by the fact that that was the turning point.
I also stand by the fact that that was the turning point from the Chris Bledsoe narrative of a
new knowledge entering the world.
I just don't think that the new knowledge entering the world, whatever it was, is something that
involves the media.
Like the idea that someone will predict an event and therefore we should expect a media
event on that date, right?
Is exactly what I just, I'm just repeating myself is the equation of the media with reality.
An event is real.
If I see it on TV, it's important if I see it on TV and if it isn't on TV or isn't on the
internet, therefore it's not a real or important event.
And that's ludicrous.
Um, so I stand by it and, you know, uh, Dan Waits can suck it, right?
Because he was wrong.
He failed.
He's failed twice.
He's going to do it again.
They're going to do it again.
They're going to fail again, right?
They don't have any interest in asking people who have thought about this and formulated how
to do it.
Well, how to do it.
Okay.
Which is fine, but it's turning RV and astrology into a circus, into a carnival, a form of
entertainment.
Um, it's exploiting it and it's muddying the waters.
This idea, buddy was here, um, alien protocols, uh, a few weeks ago.
And he pointed out that controlled RV, um, CRV, Lynn Buchanan's RV has, um, uh, timeline process
that allows viewers, this is what he said, allows viewers to predict accurately when events
will happen in the future.
It's, it's true that they have that.
They have a timeline, um, protocol in their, um, or they have a timeline.
Um, Morgan would know the right word for it.
Uh, they, they do timelines in their protocol, right?
They're the accuracy of their timelines.
That's the issue, right?
You could, anyone could say, look, I have a, I, I, uh, we can use this, um, this technique
to predict the future.
And I've refined it in such a way that I can now use this timeline to, to predict the future
more accurately, but you have to be able to demonstrate that.
And every time I've seen session data using the CRV timelines, I've seen people vary five
years or more.
If you have a group of five remote viewers, future forecasting group running a target, and
they're trying to predict a future, uh, catastrophic event that could occur, um, on the East coast
of the United States, hypothetically speaking.
And part of that prediction is to go back and have the viewers look at it using a timeline
technique and you have a variance of five years.
One is saying 2026.
One says 2027, 1000, 2028, 2029, right?
Astrology is about the, you know, a quality of a period of time, giving people windows when
events are likely to occur.
And that's not five year window, right?
I'm talking about a, a, a period of a couple of weeks.
Okay.
That's what I'm talking about.
They're talking about using it, a timeline, five viewers, and each has a different year
in a five year spread about when a catastrophic event's going to happen that could wipe out
a large group of people on the East coast of the United States.
That's junk.
That's, that's junk.
But he's a nice guy.
He is.
And he, and he has buy-in with his, um, RV protocol.
No one on earth is going to pay someone to tell them within a five year window what might
happen in the future.
Imagine if it's a straw, you went to astrology and they said, okay, well, I can tell you what
might happen.
I'll give you a five year window when it might happen.
People just turn around and walk out.
What we're talking about by using Astro RV, um, is to be able to narrow that window down
significantly and also to be able to, to expand the, the perceptual horizon that remote viewers
can use to make future predictions from the, I see that this is, this is something that's
happened in the last year where you, I see remote viewer after remote viewer making predictions
for 2040, 2050, 2060, 2100, none of them have ever demonstrated the ability to predict beyond
six to 12, 18, 18 months, right?
They have every once in a while, they accidentally predict things that happen three or five years
in the future, but there is no, I mean, Morgan connect can correct me if I'm wrong.
There is no, as far as I know, um, as far as I've ever seen remote viewing protocol that
is accurate and predicting events that far in the future until now.
Because you're going to be able to do it with Astro RV.
I guarantee it.
If people like Dan don't stop muddying the waters, making a spectacle out of it, right?
And, um, that's the word that I'm going to try to use here.
Uh, slowing adoption of the idea.
Uh, hold on.
I'm bringing up Morgan.
This is, uh, Morgan Farrell, my friend and, uh, an expert in the subject of remote viewing.
Uh, student of, um, the late, um, the late, uh, ed names may rest in peace.
Um, I added you Morgan, you should be up, but I don't know, dude, but this might be.
Yeah, no, I'm here.
It just, yeah, it just, it kind of throws you off because, you know, I'm, when I'm listening,
I'm hearing you on the, uh, seven second delay or whatever it is.
And so when I, when you jump me up to a speaker, uh, I jump, you know, I miss seven seconds of
time.
So I'm like, I don't know.
I don't.
Dude, I swear to God.
I just muted everyone by mistake.
I'm, I'm, I, I apologize.
Keep going.
Um, that was completely, but it's, there are so many impediments sometimes to, to my communicating
with others.
It's like things, weird stuff happens.
Okay, go on.
It's just me.
No, it's all good.
Um, you know, I'm kind of disappointed to see that, uh, uh, I hadn't really been involved
in spaces for a little while, but, um, you know, in the last couple of weeks I've kind
of come back and, uh, sad to, uh, report, I see zero improvement in the, uh, in the tech
since, uh, you know, late last year when I, when I was last active running them.
So that's unfortunate.
You know, I, I, I love the, I love the spaces concept.
Um, it just, it has these weird quirks that God, you'd think, uh, you'd think by this point
in time, this would be relatively simple to, uh, iron out these kinks, but they haven't
anyways, we'll, uh, we'll roll with it, uh, while we're, uh, connected.
So, okay.
I, man, I have a pile, pile of things I could, I could say.
Um, I w I would start by saying, you know, uh, blanket agree with, um, virtually everything
you've said so far tonight.
Um, you know, if I, I, I just, I, I would have to say, I, if I were to express my, my feelings
about the way that the Astro RV thing has gone so far, uh, in one word, it'd be disappointment.
I'm so disappointed that, you know, the, the cover page of, of the initial kind of concept
paper that I wrote, it says as part of the title, you know, or this, you know, this is
for the professional astrology and remote viewing communities.
And, uh, you know, I, I put it that way quite purposefully and, you know, that's the optimistic
side of me failing to recognize the fact that, uh, not everyone understands what, uh, what
it really means to be a professional.
Um, so yeah, it's, uh, it's, it's really disappointing to me that, uh, something that, you know, I put
a lot of time and effort into designing as a potential solution to one of the biggest problems we have
in remote viewing, which is affectionately referred to as the time problem.
Um, you know, it's, uh, so far, it's basically been, been a serious tool.
Uh, it's been treated as a toy.
Um, as far as I can tell more specifically for the purpose of, uh, you know, gaining influencer
status, uh, you know, likes, clicks, engagement, um, as opposed to, you know, putting in real
work testing and refining, uh, you know, a potentially really powerful tool.
And I, I just, I'm really disappointed in that.
I think it's a real shame.
Um, so that's how I feel about it.
Yeah, I hear you.
I think that, um, you know, we don't know how many people are going to watch this, uh, this
later, uh, the last space that I did that touched on, um, RV wound up having 85 people
listen to it afterwards.
Now, if, if you, if someone gets dropped and they come back, like those numbers aren't
always accurate because if someone gets dropped or they have a technical problem, they come
back, they're counted as more than one person.
Right.
But generally speaking, if someone is listening after the space, they're less likely to have
technical problems for whatever reason.
Um, so we had more people, significantly more people listen after the space.
Um, and so that might be the case.
I think everyone here knows from listening to us, but maybe not.
So the thing that makes the connection of astrology and remote viewing, um, so potentially like
it's such a game changer.
I'll use that one.
I haven't heard anyone use game changer.
A potential game changer is that the astrological, right?
So the way that I approach astrology is different than, than other people.
It's, I look at it from the original hermetic, right?
Perspective taking forward into our modern verbiage, which is that it's a, it's an analog
simulation model.
Um, so prior to having computers, um, these algorithms were developed to track, um, transpersonal
patterns in human interaction with ourselves, our environment, everything, right?
There are transpersonal patterns in human interactions all over the place.
Um, our homes, um, our nations, um, and we can't directly perceive those patterns.
Um, the only way we're able to perceive them is by using, uh, fixed points of reference, which
is what the, the planets are, they do move, but they, they move, uh, predictably.
So they're always in the same place.
And so it's, it's a, it's a way of creating, um, a fixed point or series of fixed points of
reference over a period of time that allow us to, to track and identify the patterns that
we can't directly perceive.
This was done in an experiment, 500, the longest experiment in human history.
It's called ordinary watching.
It was done by temple priests and astronomers in Babylon.
It's, it's, it's a real history.
It's, it's, it's history that most people aren't aware of.
Even people in the astrological community was 500 years every day, keeping track of where
the planets were and what the major events were in human society and the important families,
right?
They weren't able to keep track of the average person, but they were able to keep track of
the dynamics of, you know, royal families and temple families and communities and organizations,
et cetera.
I created this analog simulation model.
So the patterns that we study in astrology are going to be there and they are going to
be produce similar results 500 years or a thousand years from now.
So this is not Morgan talking.
This is me talking, right?
Because we live, uh, we're in some sort of simulation.
In my opinion, uh, there is a narrative quality to our experience and part of esoteric study,
meditation, um, studying esoteric doctrines, developing greater observer consciousness.
And as you develop greater observer consciousness, you become more aware of just how much of your
life is out of your control and how much of your life you're observing.
Most people don't, most people sort of struggle with that.
That's why people get attracted to meditation and esoteric practices because it doesn't come
naturally to most people to be an observer consciousness most of the time.
And so most people really perceive, uh, uh, a stronger connection between cause and effect
in human interactions and human relationships that are, that are really there.
Right.
And in human lives, then, then is really there, um, cause and effect of their, their own mode
of actions.
Let's put it like that.
So if you, if you remote view the future right now, let's just say, let's compare it to a character
in a book on the 30th page of an imaginary book, uh, a character may have three options that
they're thinking about for their future.
On the 130th page of, uh, of that book, right?
There is one of those options ends up being the future event that takes place.
Now you and I hold that book in our hand the same way some remote viewers and clairvoyants
see people outside, experimenters outside the simulation, holding the data from, from our
consciousness in a device and putting it on a shelf.
All right.
When you buy that book in the store, there's only one future, but on page 30 for that character,
right?
There are many real futures.
So the problem with, in my opinion, and I'm not, Morgan is an expert, but from, from where
I'm standing, the problem with predicting the future clairvoyantly without a frame of reference
is that at the time that the viewer is looking into the future, right?
That future is real for everyone involved.
Those futures that aren't going to take place are real to us in the moment.
And that's, it's, I think it's very difficult for people to reconcile that, right?
How something can both be real and not real.
But we know about this from physics, right?
Schrodinger's cat, where the cat is both alive and dead until the state has been revealed.
This is not like just something I'm making up.
So once you recognize those as all being part of the same basic principle of reality, narrative,
right?
The narrative nature of reality, quantum uncertainty, Schrodinger's cat, the fact that, you know,
future events that haven't occurred, that will never occur, are just as real to us today as
future events that will occur, right?
That makes it, I think, difficult for viewers beyond a certain point to stay on target.
And it, it's, it's predictable when you study people who look 10, 20, 30 years regularly into
the future with remote viewing, you will notice that they develop patterns where they're viewing
things based on their own preoccupations, right?
Great example, Dick from, um, future forecasting group.
When they target him to look at the future, no matter what it is, he starts spitting out the
same data, right?
So like the target could be viewer red shoe, uh, 20 years from now, and he's going to AI
computers, crypto, uh, everyone's wired into the system.
Um, he'll start spitting out the same material just because that connection for him, for whatever
reason, any future target immediately triggers that, that, that material.
When you're talking about the, the astrological transits, right?
They're going to be there and events of that type are going to happen.
So that's like giving someone real coordinates as opposed to being a coordinate row viewer and
giving someone coordinates for Afghanistan.
You can give them Afghanistan, you can give them Kabul, you can give them a house in Kabul,
right?
If they're looking for something.
Using astrology allows to give the viewer real coordinates in the future.
At a future time.
And hypothetically that they should be able, that should work in expanding their ability
to do that, that point in time.
And it's when you look back at what Sears in the past did, like if you look back at John
the revelator, Nostradamus, whatever, you'll see the connection between astrology and some
sort of clairvoyance.
That's what they practiced historically.
Um, and so that's all we're talking about is bringing that back.
And that's why it's a big deal because it could allow, right, right now we have the most
well-trained and, and perhaps the, the, the, the clairvoyance with the greatest ability,
at least as a community in human history, but we have the time problem that Morgan is talking
about, right?
So we've got this unbelievable clairvoyance, but we're not generating information about
the intermediate and distant future.
We're only generating information, uh, up to 18 months or really, I see some people come
back with three to five years, but we're not generating anything beyond that.
And we could be mapping the future, like in, in, in great detail.
Go ahead, Morgan.
I'm sorry to, I don't mean to, um, get on a soapbox.
Oh, no, not at all.
Not at all.
Um, I mean, I can add a little bit to what you're saying here.
Um, absolutely.
So, okay, so the, the time problem kind of exists in a number of ways for us, generally
speaking.
Okay.
So, you know, if you have a fixed, uh, say like, uh, uh, an outcome with like a known,
or excuse me, an event with a known, um, date of outcome, for example, election, that sort
of thing is, you know, for, for trained and experienced viewers should be relatively easy,
right?
Like, you know, we've done that and it's, it's fine.
And beyond that, um, part of the problem is there seems to be some, I don't know what
it is, but you could think of it as maybe like an interpretation issue.
Um, when it, when it comes to, okay.
So think of when, when we set up a target, we call it a, uh, in written form, it's a, it's
what we call a queue, a written queue.
Okay.
And there is a particular format, like, uh, think of it like a, a syntax and kind of
grammar and, uh, format that we use, um, in order to direct the remote viewer's attention
to a well thought out, uh, pattern of information that we're interested in retrieving.
Um, for some reason, it appears that, you know, using calendric dates and, and that sort of
language just doesn't tend to be interpreted well.
And, you know, the, the kind of the obvious analogy is, you know, like, uh, like an internet
search engine, like Google, you know, the language that you use in your Google search is going
to have a direct effect on the results that, that you would come back with.
Um, very much so with, uh, remote viewing, targeting, queuing.
Um, and as I said, calendric dates just, they just, they don't, generally speaking, they don't
work, not reliably.
Um, and then beyond that, you can, you can use particular language to, you know, direct the
viewer's attention to a, an upcoming event, such as, you know, uh, let's say, oh, I hesitate
to use a particular place, but let's say, uh, uh, location slash next natural disaster.
Okay.
Um, and, and once again, that's, you know, it's, uh, it's a superlative, so there can be only
one answer, only one, um, event that the remote viewer is to look at and sketch and describe.
Um, but again, using that kind of language, we know it's in the future because it's the
next, but we have no frame of reference as to when that is.
Okay.
So those are kind of the three typical kind of, uh, predictive scenarios that you're, that
we're going to encounter, um, in operational remote viewing.
Um, Astro RV, um, you know, in addition to everything JT's been talking about, you know,
Astro RV can actually be applied, uh, in, for predictive capabilities in a, a number of
different ways.
So for example, you know, the, um, the case I just used, uh, next, uh, place slash next
natural disaster, you know, as I said, okay, well we have, you know, let's say we've got
a lot, a good lockdown on the what and the where, but we're completely missing the, the
when astrology could be probably applied completely separately and independently from any remote
viewing to predict when that event is most likely to occur.
So that right there, you can understand, you know, what I'm getting at when I'm talking
about the potential power of this and like the, yeah, JT uses the word game changer and
potentially it is, it really is like, and this is what I can't over overemphasize how, you
know, if, if applied, uh, if executed judiciously, let's say that then you can, you can do some
serious work with this.
But, but again, you know, I, I see people who, um, for JT, you absolutely nailed it.
And I said, I've, I've seen this in remote viewing and you said, you've seen astrology people
who don't actually believe in their work, you know, like if you ask them, you know, they
might have some fantastical sounding results.
And, you know, if you, if you really nail them down on it, it's like, do you, do you believe
you're correct?
Like, do you really believe that the data that you're, you're out there presenting is the
way this is it, this is real, or, you know, are you more or less just, are you hedging yourself?
Are you hedging your bets?
You know, it's like, oh, well, you know, it's unverifiable.
So maybe it is, maybe it isn't.
Well, that frankly, in my opinion, that's unacceptable.
That's, uh, sorry, professionals don't operate that way.
Um, you know, you, you, you put something out there, you better damn well believe you're
correct.
And if you're wrong, you better damn well get back to the drawing board and figure out why.
Well, you know, people who are not professionals, they don't even know how to figure out where
they went wrong.
That's what I wanted to elaborate on is how few people are trained now, um, to recognize
real versus not real.
And how that's been a problem over the last year, we've run into a number of groups of
people who represent themselves as being experts on remote viewing, who are not trained to recognize
real targets versus fake targets.
Like I can think of a number of groups that, that that's come up with.
That's all like you, you went through specific training, right?
Can you elaborate that you went on specific training or went through specific training to,
to learn to do that and how not having that is an issue, not having that training.
It's a major issue because if you, if you fail that test, in my opinion, I, I simply won't
rely on you for, I can't rely on you for anything, literally anything.
Um, yeah, no, it's, it all starts with, you know, when I, when I talk about remote viewing,
uh, training, uh, training, I, I, I always say that, okay, uh, well, sorry, not just with
training, but with regards to becoming, uh, an effective operational remote viewer, i.e.
you can consistently and reliably use remote viewing to solve real world problems that in
many cases do not otherwise have solutions or the solution is currently unknown.
Okay.
That's what remote viewing is.
That's what it was purpose designed for from day one.
And this is what people don't understand, you know, remote viewing was, again, it was initially
conceived of as a military intelligence collection tool, i.e.
something that you can reliably take action on, gather actionable intelligence, uh, you know,
that in, in military scenarios, we're talking life and death stuff.
Okay.
Um, since it, um, moved into the private sector, courtesy of one major at dames, thank you.
Um, you know, it's, it's applications have been broadened to all sorts of things.
Like I always cite, you know, um, personal health, um, that's, that's one just incredibly
powerful use of remote viewing.
I had a conversation with one of my colleagues, uh, a couple of days ago, and he was reminding
me of a couple of, uh, jobs we did for, for someone a few years ago that, uh, you know,
just, it's incredible.
And we, we have so many people who just, they just don't, it's, I always use this, um, I
get the saying from my mother and you guys have probably all heard it.
You don't know what you don't know.
And, you know, in, in any field, you know, whether it's, it's music or if you, you know,
there's worlds of difference between a hobbyist with five years experience and a full-time
professional with five years experience, uh, compared to, let's just say, you know, virtually
any, any of the trades or, you know, nursing or whatever, you know, you're an apprentice
for your first five years, you know, on average full-time of full-time work, you're an apprentice
only then do you get your journeyman's ticket and only then you're a beginner professional
at that point with five years, full-time experience, you know, 10,000 plus hours.
And that just goes completely unrecognized.
Um, and, and that is the problem that we have here.
And, uh, sorry, JT, I kind of got off on a rant.
Where, where was I supposed to go with that?
Um, no, I just wanted to, you know, it to be clear, because if I say it right, like it
can just be someone who's like a crank, right?
Oh, you're outside the community.
Um, the, the, the collection of, or the sort of upsurge and experience remote viewers, like
the upsurge and inexperienced astrologers, um, empowered through social media, right?
To, to sort of lead and take authority over the discipline that they're not adept at.
Um, part of what they do is, uh, downplay out of necessity, they downplay the importance
of experience and training, right?
To emphasize their own strengths.
So if I go on a rant and say, look, these remote viewers aren't even trained to distinguish
between real and false targets.
Like that's true.
And that's come up.
Like that has come up with groups of people who expound as experts and release videos of
session data, video after video, and then they're all tricked by a fake target, a comic book
or a, or a, uh, uh, uh, an anime that they thought was real.
Right.
And I'm not just talking about one group.
I'm talking about a number of groups.
And you say, look, you were not correctly trained.
The, well, the pushback would be, well, what do you know?
Right.
And so the strength of having you say it is that you're an unimpeachable expert.
Okay.
I mean, people can say what they disagree, but that's a fact.
No, that's where, okay.
I'm sorry.
I, I got off on a tangent as I'm want to do, especially, I mean, I'm particularly right
now.
Um, I'm, I'm particularly passionate about this subject because, you know, with, with losing
Ed, it's really highlighted the fact that, you know, there are, there's, that leaves only
a few of us now who are, you know, basically we're, we don't, we were Ed's team.
And so it's up to us to maintain the, uh, high standards here and no one else is, uh, seemingly
willing to do it, to say anything.
So, um, that apparently has now become my role.
So that simply put that as the case.
Okay.
It all, where I was, where I was going initially was, okay, it all starts with your mindset
and your framework of understanding.
Okay.
Once again, what was the original designed purpose of remote viewing to gather actionable
intelligence?
Okay.
Now, how do you do that?
Well, you can only do that by being correct and by being accurate consistently and reliably.
Now in the framework of remote viewing, it actually ties back to something you mentioned
earlier, uh, remote viewing was very, very heavily, um, based, uh, on the framework of understanding
of, you know, conscious and unconscious, uh, human psychology, um, of Carl Jung.
Okay.
So the, it's, it's entirely compatible and it's, it's actually largely based around that framework
of understanding.
Okay.
That said, what we're doing with remote viewing is we are sending our minds out loosely speaking.
To retrieve a particular pattern of information, which exists at the core fundamental layer of
reality.
Okay.
If you train yourself from day one to do that, you bypass any and all obstacles that JT has
hinted at earlier, you know, such as, uh, biases, wants, or desires of, uh, the, the tasker or the
project manager or the client, um, you know, to do anything else is a critical error.
You know, it's so that right there from day one, you need to go into remote viewing with
the correct understanding, uh, or, or mindset.
Okay.
From there, it's a matter of training and experience.
All right.
And that takes time.
There's no substitute for time.
You know, that's just the way it is.
And, um, there, there seems to be, uh, no understanding of that and no respect for that.
And it's, it's a real shame because, you know, I, I frequently, I see people making, you know,
what I, what I consider beginner mistakes, intermediate level mistakes that if they just had, again,
what I consider beginner and intermediate level training, you know, these people would be
light years ahead and there, there's no real interest in that probably.
I think, you know, you're right for a lot of the reasons you mentioned earlier.
And, you know, there, there may be, you know, who knows, you know, well, I can say, I can
say one thing about remote viewing, right?
Um, there's a cult of a hero mentality, right?
The cult of the hero mentality in our society.
And the way that materialized in remote viewing was when everyone left the program, right?
The way people marketed themselves was to focus on the strength of the remote viewer.
And then the inference was, well, if I'm the best remote viewer in the program, one of the
best, therefore I'm the best qualified to teach you.
And that's completely asked backwards.
Now we have that going on everywhere in our society where we say, like, if that person is
the best at what they do, therefore they're the best teacher.
There was a two completely separate, two completely separate things.
Right.
You don't find, like, how often do you find the best athletes are the best coaches?
Like how, you just don't find that very often where you, because it's two different abilities.
And with, with, and I don't mean any disrespect to Ed, um, the way Ed approached remote viewing,
right, was not from the perspective of being like the heroic remote viewer.
He didn't approach it.
And everyone else left the program and they all went out there to, to show out, right?
To show off how good they were at what they did.
But they didn't have the knowledge and experience or the mentality to expand the uses of remote
viewing or to critically look at themselves and other remote viewers or the experience in
training other remote viewers.
It was all just based on personal competence.
And no matter, we've all had this, I guarantee you everyone here has had this experience.
You have worked at a job where you have people who are put in charge based on their personal
competence, right?
They used to call us the Peter principle in the seventies.
I was born in the seventies.
I don't remember it called the Peter principle where people are promoted to their own personal
level of competence, right?
So you would have, um, you go into a job, it could be anything, right?
And your boss was promoted because they're, they were competent at, at their developing relationships
with their bosses and that the, the particular details of what they do, they're completely incompetent
at, at training others, at leading a team of coming up with solutions to problems.
And immediately it becomes a complete shit show.
I guarantee we've all had that experience.
Well, that's what happened in remote viewing where you had people who, again, like they,
they were, you know, they marketed themselves to recruit students based on their personal
competence as remote viewers, not as related to their competence as trainers.
Right.
They didn't even have that mentality.
So that's one of the things that differentiates.
And Morgan and I had this conversation.
We were talking about one remote viewer in particular, and his, his school has an affinity
for spreadsheets.
And these spreadsheets track every detail of the performance of an individual viewer.
So does he look, work well viewing cars?
Does he or she, do they work well viewing deer?
Do they work well finding missing people?
Do they work well, you know, looking, sensing the temperature, ambient temperature of their environment?
We're talking hundreds of metrics, hundreds of metrics, parsing the details of the individual
strengths and weaknesses of their remote viewers.
So the problem with that is, is that, and I, Morgan can correct me, right?
But generally speaking, if you're, if you're designing a team of people, right, to, to forecast and
predict things, to find things, to bring back actual intelligence, you're, you're designing
a team of people.
You're not parsing to see which specific person has a slight incremental advantage in each,
right?
So instead of saying like, Sally is 1.5% better at this type, this type of remote viewing.
So we're going to go with what Sally says.
Instead, right?
You're training everyone to be a better viewer.
And you're looking at the aggregate data.
Bark like a duck, Melissa, Blue, Sally, and Morgan.
Now we're going to analyze the data and we're going to come up with the, the best data that
comes out of the aggregate of the group's sensing, right?
It, it, it, it's sabotage removing right from the very beginning.
And it created this like competition and this negative perfectionism.
Whereas Ed, like he, he immediately came into it with the mentality of someone looking at
the technical details of improving remote viewing and the technical details of being
a good trainer, right?
And I remember I was there in the nineties and in the two thousands and they would honestly
go out and say like, cause Ed was the man and they honestly would go out and attack and
be like, back in the program, Ed wasn't considered to be a good remote viewer.
I was the best remote viewer.
That's how they, that's what happened.
And then everyone's like, Oh really?
Okay.
Well, we want to go with the person who was the best remote viewer.
Right.
And then now we're, there are three generations on and it's a complete clusterfuck in my opinion,
although I'm not personally part of it.
Um, go ahead more.
Um, yeah.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You're, you're, you're spot on man.
And, um, and it's not, and now, you know, let me be clear.
It's not a knock.
Against, um, literally anyone.
Um, I have tremendous respect for, uh, you know, every single person that was involved
in, um, the, what was ultimately called the Stargate program.
Uh, I, I do, I really do.
Um, but you're, you're entirely correct.
And let me be, I can say with, you know, I, I hesitate to use the word authority, but I,
like, technically that's actually, I suppose true in this case, I can say with 100% with
direct knowledge that, um, Ed was acutely aware that he was not the best remote viewer.
He was, he would openly admit that.
Um, he, he, he, he said to me personally, he said that me, Morgan, I'm a better remote
viewer than, than he ever was.
He said that to me.
Okay.
And that is not to say that I'm the best remote viewer.
I will also never say that, um, I'm not, um, I'm, I'm decent.
I'm, I'm pretty good viewer overall, but I'm absolutely not the best.
Uh, I kinda, at least I like to think I kind of take after Ed in that sense that, um, I'm
actually much more interested in the application and the expansion, um, of remote viewing.
You know, um, I've, I've actually been saying that quite openly for the last few years that
I'm, I'm a whole lot less interested in, in actively remote viewing than I am, uh, teaching
and acting, you know, as a project manager and that, and that sort of thing.
Um, but yeah, you're, you're absolutely correct.
And I think the comparison to sports, you know, where the, the best athlete is by no means
likely to be the best coach.
Um, I think that's perfectly apt.
And it's just, it's a near universal truth and you keep using the word mentality and you're
exactly correct.
Ed had that mentality.
He saw and understood the mechanics of what was going on with remote viewing.
Um, and he also saw the issues and limitations inherent there in, and when he took it, um, private,
you know, in, uh, 1989, I think it was when SciTech opened up and, you know, over the next,
you know, however many years, uh, working with a lot of the military viewers and early with,
with Ingo Swann on staff, um, as consultants and, uh, you know, viewers.
Um, he really led the charge in expanding and broadening the application of remote viewing
beyond its traditional, you know, military intelligence roots.
He, he, he's the one who figured out he, he basically, he, and in doing so identified a
lot of the, a lot of the inherent limitations and the problems.
And he did what he could, where he could to correct for those problems.
And he did a, an incredible, incredible job.
And this is something that is not at all broadly understood in the remote viewing community,
not at all.
Um, a lot of the criticisms that I've heard from, you know, the, the top dogs, um, from
the long history of Stargate are that, oh, you know, Ed's technical remote viewing TRV method
is just an arbitrarily rearranged CRV method.
That couldn't be further from the truth.
The reason TRV, the, if I described TRV method as streamlined and refined, okay, it's actually
the third would be efficient.
Actually, that's probably the best word.
It's efficient.
It takes a lot of what I view personally.
And, you know, we can have this technical debate discussion all day long, but I, in my
view, it, it takes CRV to the next level.
It makes it, um, just again, more efficient.
Um, and he just, you know, yeah, he, it doesn't, people, people don't understand.
And it's just, it's so sad.
It's such a shame.
Um, but, uh, Hey, can I jump in, you know?
Yeah.
So I wanted to do a space on this last week and you guys ran your, your space and I went
back and forth for a number of reasons.
And I ended up just deciding it wasn't the right time and I couldn't think of anything
else.
So I just canceled the space.
And I think, I think I canceled the space and just put it off.
Um, I wanted to do one on Saturday.
Um, in brief, uh, my brother's a computer engineer.
I have a younger brother.
I have two younger brothers, but one of them significantly younger and he's a computer engineer
and I don't know much about AI.
And so I wanted to, um, I wanted to learn more about it.
Um, so I had him explain it to me and he was able to cut like all the cut to all the superfluous
stuff and explained to me like how it worked and how it can be used efficiently and like
why people are going crazy, which I kind of already knew, but like, you know, how to manage
the AI system.
Anyhow, prior to that conversation, I was 90% certain that we lived in some level of simulation.
And I said, there's a 10% chance that we're just not interpreting the data correctly.
Right?
Like there's the data is there.
It's historical, it's 2000 years, it's all over the place, but maybe there's just a factor
we don't know.
After that conversation with my brother, like I, there's not a doubt in my mind anymore.
It's a hundred percent, not, not 10%.
As soon as he started explaining AI, I started to say, oh shit.
Like, it's amazing to me that people don't, um, recognize the correlation.
I, someone who is sort of, um, not an adversary of mine, cause they don't really know I exist,
but someone who's ideologically, uh, an ideological adversary of mine is, uh, is, is Brian Johnson,
right?
With his, uh, live forever stuff.
Um, he, he recently did some DMT and like, he did some mushrooms.
Then he did some DMT and it was like a promotional thing, but it's also like those substances can
have, uh, rejuvenating effects on the brain, right?
Like physically rejuvenating effects on the brain.
So they wanted to do the experiment.
He's a famous person.
So he went through with the experiments and he came out with some like new understanding.
And he recently posted on X.
He said, you know, now that I've been through this, like, I can't help, but think of human
beings and AI agents, um, similarly, uh, hold on.
Uh, similarly, right.
Uh, I apologize.
I'm actually in the middle of two things at one time, um, which is rude.
So I could not agree more.
I didn't have to do the DMT.
All I had to do was have AI explained to me.
And the first thing I thought of following this explanation was like, just how much it
highlights the strength of technical remote viewing.
I think we, we didn't have an efficient metaphor to explain it to people.
Um, like Morgan's very efficient to explain, like it is very articulate, right?
And so it was that, but we didn't necessarily have the right metaphor to explain it on the
level that we needed it to be right.
Or the level necessary.
Um, and I think that we do now.
And I think that, uh, I, I think it all, it all pulls together.
So I wanted to run a space on that, on Ed, Ed's legacy, and also share like what insights
I might have from, as an outsider.
Um, yeah.
So I wanted to do that this Saturday.
Now it turns out that Morgan is back and he's going to be doing a regular Saturday, um, space
in the afternoon, which I highly recommend.
He's the only person with his level of expertise who's running any type of spaces on the subject
of remote viewing.
And that's just a fact, right?
So if you, if you want to know, you would go with Morgan and he's correct in the, the, uh,
criticisms of technical remote viewing are, are false criticisms because they start with
flawed assumptions.
That's also accurate.
I've always said, you know, I've spent 30, more than 30 years.
There's a 30, you know, it's been about 30 years, right?
Since public, like following the remote viewing community and following the careers of individual
remote viewers.
And I find technical remote viewers to be on the whole better remote viewers.
I do.
There are some people who have tremendous gifts, but they have flaws in their training, right?
So they come from other schools or flawed assumptions.
Um, and that's one of the things that brought Morgan and I together.
Uh, Morgan, if you are available, I mean, probably gonna be all talked out or you may do another
10 hour space because as we talked about, like 10 hours seems to be your natural comfort
zone.
What like space is on remote viewing.
Um, that's kind of a joke, but, uh, he, he does do 10 hour spaces.
And then he, afterwards he says, like, I can't believe I was on it for 10 hours.
If you're around, uh, and you want to join the space, feel free.
If you're too burned out, um, understandable, having your expertise is better in conversations
about the subject and I won't focus entirely on Ed because if you or someone else from the
TRV community isn't there, then it's not, I'm just going to muddy the waters, but I do
want to talk about like what I know about TRV and Ed's career that, you know, this new
understanding that I have, like it clearly demonstrates why it's superior and also why
we need you guys, like why we need Ed Dames right now.
Right.
Like it's, it's ironic that this is the time when we need Ed Dames and Ed is passed on.
And there are a few of you who are Ed Dames now, right?
You're the representation of Ed Dames.
Um, I know a couple that I, I don't know who are, you know, but it's a small group.
Um, so yeah, you're, you're welcome to join.
If not, that's, that's understandable.
Uh, it's, it's time for me to wrap up the space.
Are you there, Morgan?
But I just want to make sure that you're, that, that you were there and you, and cause
it shows me like, um, it doesn't show me sometimes when people leave or when they join for whatever,
like I get the, the screen freezes with the icons.
Um, so there were some things I didn't get a chance to talk about today.
Uh, aside from the TRV slash, um, Ed Dames slash AI, uh, stuff, which I want to talk about
on Saturday, if that, if that, if it's possible, if anyone wants to join me and if not, you
know, if Morgan's space is going and it's eight o'clock and they're, they're going strong,
stick with his space.
I can always do it in another day.
Right.
Um, uh, I haven't, well, not that I did previously, but I have no intention of running for 10 hours.
That's okay.
I'm just saying like, I'm saying your space on Saturday, this Saturday, your space should
take precedence is what I'm saying.
If you're done right.
And people who are in that space want to come over, that's great.
If not, that's fine.
If there are people here who want to talk or listen, then, then I'm, I'm going to run
a space and that's what I want to talk about.
That's all.
But I hear you.
I know you don't plan to.
There were a couple of other things I didn't cover that I said I was going to cover.
Um, I was going to talk about Doomer's data spaces or data, data centers.
The data centers are a thing.
And they're a thing on a bunch of different levels.
And everyone's got theories about what is really going on with the data centers.
And, uh, it's come up with Doomer.
I call them Doomer's data centers because it's, it's a pro, you know, he's got a pole shift.
Uh, he had three eye Atlas and now he's got the data centers as a preoccupation.
Uh, I boycott the Doom room.
I don't boycott Doomer daddy.
Those are entirely sort of different things.
That's a sort of a complicated scenario that's developed.
Um, but I do have some communication with Doomer daddy.
So that is, um, that's why I call them Doomer daddies, uh, uh, data centers.
I will talk about that, um, next week, uh, perhaps on maybe on Saturday, but probably next
week, um, if I can work it into a space, I just, I'm sure no one here will be disappointed
that I didn't talk about the data centers, but I feel like I should account for things
I say that I'm going to do that I don't do, which unfortunately with me is, is not a small
product.
It's not a small issue.
I also want to do some housekeeping.
I think I'm going to run an hour long space tomorrow.
If anyone wants to listen to me, you don't have to, um, no one has to, right?
Like I don't usually do spaces on Fridays.
No one shows up when I do, but I'm going to talk about what's going on with UFO X because
I made some spaces a year ago predicting some things that would happen with UFO X and it
seems like they're happening and it's, it's kind of gotten this really kind of, um, because
it's a really kind of dark place where people like getting sick and they're having accidents
and other people gloating over it and, and claiming that they're harnessing like non-human
intelligence in order to do these things to each other.
And it's just kind of a shit show and it's not really productive.
We're at a certain point in time, right?
We're all having this sort of like important center of experiences and this is really counterproductive
right now.
So I just wanted to like sort of record it and then anyone who's interested can, can listen
to it later.
If they have, if they want to hear my perspective, they don't, they don't have to.
Um, and then Saturday we're doing the, um, RV slash AI thing.
Um, so that's all I've got.
Does anyone have anything else?
Morgan, you got anything else before we go?
Don't think so.
Um, but yeah, no, I will, um, I'll look to, um, I'd like to be there on Saturday.
What time are you thinking?
Well, I'm going to start at, um, uh, seven on Saturday, but I should be going for a couple
hours if anyone is interested.
Okay.
Yeah, no, that should work.
Uh, well, I'll, I'll try and keep my space relatively precise.
But look, yours is important, right?
Like yours is important.
So it's important to get this data out now.
And, uh, you know, Hey, I just wanted to say before I go, like, I appreciate you coming
back to the space and, um, I know everyone appreciates having you, having you here and your,
your perspective and your experience is invaluable.
And it really is something that I, you know, would be difficult for me to, you know, like
would be difficult for me to find anywhere else or anyone to find anywhere else.
So I, I just want to let you know, I appreciate you coming and joining the space whenever you
can, um, and bringing that experience.
So, um, can everyone else's, you can tell because we're all making emojis to say that
they experienced it or they, they appreciate it.
Um, so I will, uh, I do have to go cause I have this eight o'clock thing and I'm running
late, uh, but I hope to see everyone tomorrow or Saturday and, uh, there'll be a 15 sec.
I appreciate everyone.
Uh, right now the images I can see are Sally, Morgan, Barkley, Dr. Melissa, Blue and Sinan.
I appreciate you all.
Um, you're regulars of my spaces and that really means a lot to me.
Thank you.
Um, there'll be a 15 second or seven second delay and then the space will end.
Okay.